we've already talked about kinetic
energy for an object that's rotating and
translating let's take again a simple
object like a wheel center of mass is
moving and we want to consider this is a
bunch of point-like particles the Jade
particle with mass MJ and a position
vector R CM J and now what we'd like to
do is how do what is the angular
momentum of this about some point P and
we're going to do the same type of
decomposition that we've been doing
right along let's draw the vector R J
this is the vector from the point P to
the object here's the vector capital R
and there's the vector R CM J and our
same vector addition r plus r CM j now
let's calculate the angular momentum
about the point P now just let's recall
two facts about the center of mass
reference frame that we've already used
the first is that the sum of the
velocities the momentum in the
center-of-mass reference frame is zero
and if you integrate this equation in
just exactly the same way if you added
up the mass times each of the position
vectors that's MJ MJ in the
center-of-mass frame that's also zero so
we'll use we've used this when we talked
about kinetic energy now we're going to
consider both of these results so recall
that angular momentum about a point is
the sum of the vector from the point
cross product MJ times the velocity BJ
now we can also use our law of addition
velocities V J is the plus the CM J and
so now we're going to have to do both
substitutions in here that's why this
calculation is a little bit more
complicated
we have our plus our CM j cross MJ x
capital V that is the velocity of the
center of mass with respect to the
ground frame plus b CM J now we have
four terms in the cross product and this
time we'll write them all out so the
first term is the sum over J of our
cross MJ capital D the second term is
we'll take this one and we'll cross with
that one but because MJ is just a scalar
I'm gonna pull it in front so that's MJ
r CM j and V is the same for every
single particle in the object remember V
is just the velocity of one reference
frame with respect to the other so I can
pull that out cross B and you're already
noticing that this term will be zero the
next term is when I take our cross MJ v
j the center of mass j summed over j
that's J our cross MJ b CM j but again
remember that r is the same vector it's
just from p to the center of mass so i
didn't need to put the sum here i can
pull our out of the sum and i have my
son like that
and again you're probably noticing that
this term is zero and our final term is
our CM j cross m jb c MJ so our final
term is some r r CM j cross MJ b CM j
now from these two conditions one and
two both of these two terms are 0 and
that's the power of using the center of
mass reference frame so LP now let's
look at the first term here our
the same for every particle these the
same for every particle when we're
summing over the mass we're just getting
the total mass so the first piece is our
cross and total V and this last piece is
precisely the definition of the angular
momentum of the j DH particle in the
center-of-mass frame so that's the sum
over J of LC MJ because our cm cross MV
j r cross say whatever speed this is in
the center-of-mass frame it could be at
some v CM j VJ - capital D this is
exactly the angular momentum of that j
DH mass in the center of mass frame and
when we total all of this up
we have our cross M total D plus L cm
now what this first term is is if you
treated the whole object as a point mass
M total moving with feed and here's our
point P and there's our this is just
what we call the translational angular
momentum it's treating the whole system
as a point like mass and just calculate
moving with speed V and that's just the
angular momentum we've called this V and
this piece is the angular momentum about
center of mass so sometimes we can think
of the angular momentum as corresponding
to a translational that has to do with
the actual orbit of the object you could
call this orbital angular momentum and
this is the fact that the object is
rotating you could think of this as the
spin angular momentum about the center
of mass this is the same type of
decomposition that we saw with kinetic
energy there was a translational
component of kinetic energy and a
rotational component content kinetic
energy
this is the analogous case for angular
momentum about a point P